okay
we're now recording so as always
recordings of our virtual meetups will
be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on the meetup board
when the recording is ready next i am
very pleased to introduce our speaker
today
victoria bellotti victoria bellotti
is currently a student at the illinois
institute of technology
she is expected to graduate in december
2021
with a bachelor of science in applied
mathematics
bachelor of science and statistics and a
master of science in computational
decision science and operations research
her academic interests include data
science
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
if you'd like to ask questions victoria
is open to questions throughout the talk
so just put them in the chat and also
keep an eye on them
take it away victoria hello thank you
for having me here today
so i'll start by showing my screen
not that that's for later and then here
we go and we can get started
um so today my talk is about topological
estimation of image data via sub
sampling
and this work was done as part of a
research experience for undergraduates
program
at the university of north carolina at
greensboro funded by the nsf
and here are my co-authors matt jester
and then dr
caitlin keegan dr yuman chung and dr
sarah day who
like helped me like mentored me
throughout this project
so there's some motivation behind the
work that we did here
so there's this con there's this a
concept called fern ice
which is where you have a glacier like
imagine greenland or antarctica
in this particular case we use greenland
because that's where the data was
collected from
and at the top of like a layer of
glacier you have like the softer snow
which has like just fallen or fallen
over
a period of time and at the very bottom
of the glacier you have very solid
ice so there's a transition layer
between the ice and the snow called
fern and in the fern there are these
pockets of air
and these coastal pockets of air in the
fern can contain air that has been
preserved
for thousands of years so it's of
interest to climate scientists because
these these little air pockets contain a
window into what the environment looked
like thousands of years ago
so they want to find and study these
pockets of air in the firm
and so the goal of this project was to
estimate the number of air pockets
which is also known as two-dimensional
holes which i'll explain
in a bit and within this block of fern
and the challenge is that the structure
of the fern is unknown
and that the calculation is very
computationally expensive which i will
also discuss on in a little bit
so for some background um so first we
need to introduce this concept in
algebraic topology called betting
numbers
and so basically these numbers
characterize like
what an item is or how many holes it has
almost so betty 0 or beta 0
is the number of zero dimensional holes
or connected components
a bit more intuitive you have intuitive
you have the betty one which is the
number of one-dimensional holes or
tunnels
and betty 2 is the number of
two-dimensional holes or air pockets
and to give some visualization to what
these all mean
a biscuit is a zero-dimensional hole
which basically means it's solid it has
no holes
and so it has one zero dimensional hole
and zero one and two dimensional holes
a doughnut is a has one
uh zero dimensional hole which is the
this is the donut material itself the
part you eat
and then it has one one dimensional hole
which is the hole in the center of it
similarly a pretzel has one zero
dimensional hole and then but in this
case it has
three a one-dimensional holes and then a
basketball
like the the material of the ball itself
is a one zero dimensional hole
and then the air within consists of
two-dimensional hole
because it's hollow and then another
concept we have is called sub-level set
filtration
so we have this grayscale image of some
rice
and basically we divide it into two sets
based on so um going back to it so the
grayscale image the pixel values range
from 0 to 255
and so we have some value t which is
between 0 and 255
and we want to binarize the image such
that
if the if the pixel value is less than t
then it if you make it black if it's
greater than t or if it's not in this
set here you make it white
and it's a way of binarizing the image
and as you increase t so like when t
is low a lot of the image is just white
but then as you increase t
it becomes more and more black so t when
you set t to zero
then it's all um white and if you set t
to 255 then it's all black
and we want to binarize the image
because that helps us perform like the
topological persistent homology
calculations later on
so here's this concept of persistent
homology on images
so basically using the the affirmations
thresholding
so if the value is less than threshold
the pixel is black else it's white
and so here's just here's just an item
it's like a rod with two
round objects at the end and as you
increase
the the layer t you can see that the
first the bar in the middle disappears
because here like the
bar is a bit darker than the than this
part on the left
and then as you increase it further and
the round object on the left disappears
and then you're just left with
the round object on the right and so
what we want to characterize here
is when the object quote-unquote is born
and when it dies
so the object's born when it first
appears like at the lowest value of t
where it can appear so in this case this
whole object appears when t is zero
and then the object dies when it no
longer is when it's all black when it's
no longer visible
so this round object here
it's born so when you start off it
doesn't really it doesn't
because it's not perfectly white it
doesn't appear until t
till time is 50 and then when you get
the level time of 100
um then it disappears or sorry not that
it shouldn't be the round thing it
should be the bar in the middle
and then this object here like just
it starts off at the beginning and it
doesn't disappear until the very end
and when the object when the object
separates
oh yeah here's this object here is
created when this bar disappears and
that's how
you get the t the birth of 50.
and then because when this breaks apart
you have a new object
and then we have this concept called
persistence diagrams which is taking the
birth and the death
of each of these objects and then
plotting it on a chart
so we have the one that was born at zero
and dies at 255
and then the other one that was born at
50 and dies at 110
and those are just the corresponding
cards and then this piece here
it just uh born at 50. and then so what
we want to characterize
is the lifespan which is the death minus
the birth of the object and
long life span features are what we're
really interested in because if
the lifespan is longer it usually
indicates that the object is actually in
the image it's not just a piece of noise
or something so
the long we want to find these long
lifespan images which are usually
grouped in the upper left-hand side of
this
of these persistence diagrams and so
one of my mentors dr yuman chung and dr
sarah day are two of them
uh they had this idea called persistence
diagram thresholding
which is find the threshold to binaries
a grayscale image
such that you you think it's the true
version of the image it's not
it like minimizes the noise and it
basically captures what the image
actually looks like
and then you can actually count the
number of
long lifespan features so
the method is you have these three
regions of size so it's just psi
and then psi plus and then psi minus and
then so
just normal side you want to select the
long lifespan features
and then these are late born features
and then these are early dead features
and basically you want to find the arg
max of
multiplying uh then these each have some
algebraic representation which basically
you end up
uh you want to maximize this part and
penalizing these two parts
and this um algorithm where you can if
you want to see the specifics of it you
can look at
their paper but yeah so basically you
want to
find the most find the features that
correspond to the most true features
and so just here's an example of a
persistence diagram so here's an
original image of fern
and i'll explain more on how this image
was found in a little bit
and basically um they performed the pd
thresholding algorithm on here
and basically these purple dots
represent like what's
supposed to be the true features and
these two you can see this distribution
is kind of bimodal of like the noisy
features
where it's like it's born early and then
uh dies early or
the converse and this is what the image
looks like when it was binarized so you
can see that
it mostly captures the true appearance
of these
of the ice these circles here are just a
camera error so they don't represent
anything about the ice it's just a
camera
part of the data but yeah aside from
that it basically captures what's
actually there
and so now to describe what this fern
data actually is
so the box of ice so one of my mentors
dr caitlin keegan
she actually she and a team actually go
to greenland and they dig up these ice
these fern ice samples from the glacier
it's really cool and basically so they
dig up blocks of fernice from 10
different depths
ranging from 7 meters to 78 meters and
then
they use x-ray micro computed tomography
or
micro ct devices to scan the fern stable
and generate these 3d images
and then each 3d image consists of a
stack around 600
700 2d grayscale images so let me just
go back
a second so this one slice is just one
single slice or layer
from like a three dimensional or about
maybe about 700
images and so that's the
three-dimensional so that's what the
data is
and here are just more examples of the
of the firm data
as you can see anything that looks like
a circle around that's just camera
error but basically the white parts are
the ice and then the black parts
are the sorry no i have it backwards the
black parts are the solid yeah the black
parts the ice and then the white parts
are the holes in the ice
and those are what we want to
characterize
so one of the main packages used within
this project was the gudi library
and gudi stands for geometry
understanding in higher dimensions
and it's an open source python library
that contains specialized data
structures such as cubicle complexes
and simplical complexes and these
calculate the persistent homology like
they do the things that i just talked
about where
it calculates it does like the sub-level
set filtration
betty numbers finding all that stuff and
from there we can use and then we
manually implemented
a dr chung's like pd thresholding
algorithm in python using numpy
and then you hear other main python
packages used throughout this project
where
opencv numpy and multi-processing i'll
be talking more about parallelization
later on
so as i said before one of the main
issues of this was run time complexity
and so to test out like one this was in
the preliminary stages of the project
testing out applying a manual to the
image of runtime calculations
using goodie so what goodie does is
it takes the image or the 1d or the 2d
or 3d image
and it basically does all these
calculations and it tries to calculate
the true
number the true betting number of either
a 1d
or sorry either 2d or a 3d image
and this was just some data i found
where i used so many slices and now this
took this was a very long time and
this was just me running it on my own
computer and as you can see the plot
looks linear
which in itself is would be bad given
the size because like i said in
actuality we want to run this on like
700 or 800
uh slices because that's the full data
side and we want to do that 10 times
over for the 10 deaths
but in actuality the runtime growth is
cubic i just didn't use enough slices to
actually see the cubic growth of it
because like when you look at the like
the mathematics of it and my mentor told
me that's it's actually cubic so that's
even worse than what i had suspected
so we very much needed to find a way to
do this faster
so some other background on things we
did was image pre-processing
so we want to decrease the runtime and
improve the accuracy of pd thresholding
through smoothing and noise reduction
because these images by themselves
they're also
quite noisy because if sometimes they
just have spurious pixels
around the image or like i said they
have that error the circular
imprints so things like that
cause more inaccurate results sometimes
when you do the pd thresholding
calculation
so we have two approaches um the main
one that we use mostly throughout the
project is singular value decomposition
which is where you have an image matrix
a is decomposed in the proc of three
matrices
u s and v transpose where s is the
matrix of singular values
and keeping fewer singular values lowers
memory size and complexity
and here's just an example of on this
image of some parts
so the true image has a betting number
of five
eleven and zero because it has five
black components like the main the
background
and then the inside of each of these
little holes and that has eleven
one dimensional holes which are the the
white parts or
sorry no oh sorry i misspoke so this is
the true betty number is five comma
eight because there's eight of the parts
but
it calculate on the original image pd
threshold and calculated 5 comma 11
which was incorrect
and then so when we kept fewer and fewer
singular values you could see that was
only
so the maximum number of things singular
values is like the
like the rank of the image so to speak
so that would be about the size of the
image which was
i'm not sure i think was like 250 so
yeah so the maximum number of senior
values was about 250
and we only kept 30 of them and you can
see that the image
was still it's still basically the same
image and the accuracy is much greater
and the runtime goes
down by a little a little under half
and i generally found that using about
20 singular values was the best
because you can see it's perf it's
accurate it gets the 5 comma 8 which is
what we want
and also it decreases runtime by saying
about a little under half
and it but on the other hand if you use
too few singular values
here it's both inaccurate i mean it gets
faster but it's quite inaccurate like
here's two comma eight
and then using only five you can't even
really see the original image much
and it's three comma 10. so yeah i found
that 20 to 30 but mainly 20 was like the
best amount to use so to speak
and then another image pre-processing
method that we
tested was mathematical morphology which
is where it utilizes dilation erosion
opening closing operators to transform
an image
and operators are based on the
structuring element which is usually a
rectangular ellipse or cross
and basically what it does if you know
anything about neural networks or
convolutional neural networks
where you have the filter that convolves
across the image it kind of works
similarly to that where the structuring
element is applied across the image
and then one of the these four
operations were performed so it's sort
of like a moving window
that performs the operation at each at
each iteration of the filter
and you hear moves as a window and then
here's just the
the different impacts of the image so
here we have the original image again
and then uh here's where you can apply
we applied the rectangle
structuring element the ellipse and the
cross and if you look closely you could
see that these kind of look like tiny
rectangles these kind of look like tiny
circles or ellipses
and then these kind of look like tiny
crosses in the background and as you can
see here
the ellipse and the cross actually got
it right it got the right amount of
betty numbers
and both reduced run time by about half
and it but the bet the in this case
since we're working with holes and those
are generally circular
the ellipse was generally the best but
it really depends on what kind of data
you're working with because if you have
more like rectangular shapes then you
would probably want to use the rectangle
one
or even the cross one performed well
here
so just to show the impact of what
happens before and after applying the
the svd to sing your value decomposition
so here
uh we so one thing we'll talk about soon
is sampling and basically we took
30 samples from an image and you can see
and then we calculated the betting
numbers
on each of them and you can see here
that or sorry
so um here a real
hole is constituted when it's like
completely within the image
so like even though this contains sort
of a hole it's not counted because it's
not enclosed so the ones highlighted in
yellow here are the ones
that contain true holes so to speak and
so but here you can see that
in this area here it's very noisy like
this says this is telling me there's
98 holes in sample nine and you can see
that's
not true because there are no holes here
and these image these samples that
contain no holes tended
to produce really strange results and so
if we go to the next slide
you can see that once you once we smooth
the data
well sample 9 still was a bit strange
but most of them for the most part
accurately said that there were no holes
so you can see that
comparing these two this is a lot more
noisy and it picks up that noise whereas
here the noise is reduced
and you get much more accurate results
so now we'll go into the sampling
approaches because the core one of the
core parts of our ultimate
algorithm is performing sampling and so
these first three here were just things
we tried but ultimately the periodic
boundary sampling was the best one and
i'll go into explain each of these and
the problems with the first three
so so truncated sampling was just was
pretty straightforward just
let l be the desired length of a size of
a sample square
and then you randomly choose a pixel in
the image and then form a square
extending out from it
and then if it extends past the boundary
of the image just ignore that part just
only keep what's within the image
and as you might suspect the big issue
with that
is that you're just cutting off part of
it like
and the image the samples the samples
may vary in size
here's just an example of taking a
possible sample from the
from the edge and then yeah you could we
want these all the samples to be uniform
to be like a square
and this one just is a rectangle and
also
it causes it may cause issues because
you're not equally sampling
well you're not equally stan the samples
aren't all of equal size
so a one way to fix that is to do
restricted sampling which
it's similar in that you just randomly
choose a pixel
and then form a sample by extending out
from that pixel
but here we're constructing the domain
to only be pixels that
don't go past the boundary and
the main issue with that or here i'll
show the image to show
so basically we're constraining the
initial random pixel to only be within
this domain
so if you pick here it'll still extend
but it won't go past if you pick here
it'll go past
and as you can see the issue is that it
causes under sampling from regions not
within the district
uh the restricted sampling domain so
this also it was a bit better than the
truncated one but still not that great
because we want equal
representation from like basically if we
treat
the image as our population size like if
you're thinking of normal sampling from
like say a population of people
like this whole square is our population
size and we don't want to undersample
from
these parts
and so another thing a slightly
different approach for grid sampling
instead of randomly choosing it just use
a predefined grid of samples
uh it's kind of similar to stratified
sampling although not quite
and then here i'll show you the image uh
yeah and so the issue is that it may
still cause under sampling from certain
regions
and also it removes the randomness and
we kind of rely on the randomness
to to develop an estimator later on and
here's just some
ideas like splitting so first you split
the grid into like a four by four grid
of squares and sample from there or you
could sample like
just the vertical one or the vertical
ones and then the horizontal ones and
then just the inner square
and these different like overlays were
to try and capture every possible
place a hole could be such as if they're
let's say
just looking at these two squares here
just the black squares if there's a hole
that lies on the boundary we want to
capture that by using the green square
similarly with the yellow square and
then with the blue square it's capturing
like where the
the edge if a whole lies on the edge of
another sort of grid
and this was this had this one wasn't
the best because like i said you can't
really develop an estimator but it was
just an interesting concept
of a possible way to do the sampling so
now here's the ultimate way we ended up
you doing the sampling throughout the
rest of the project and it was the best
way that we found
periodic boundary sampling so you have
an image
and again as before you randomly choose
a pixel and
form a square of size l by l extending
out from that pixel
and then if the square extends past the
border you wrap it around to the other
side of the image which is kind of like
a periodic boundary condition where
here you can see it this part here this
part of the image
comes from maybe around here so yeah i
think this part
and so since it extends past the bottom
so like think about with truncated
sampling
you just go past the boundary and then
you don't do anything whereas here when
you go past the boundary you wrap around
to the other side so it goes here
and then it wraps around to the top and
then samples from the top of the other
side
and then here when it goes out it and it
still works if you go out the corner
like let's say your initial pixel is
here
and it goes out here it then wraps
around to the other side here and wraps
around to the top and to the bottom
so you can see it's kind this line here
sort of demarcates where the four
pieces meet so you're basically
stitching it together so
in concept it's kind of like a manifold
where it just kind of infinitely
you have almost like infinite space but
you don't really but it's just within
the
within the definition of the parameters
and the
and the wrapping around here that you
get that
so yeah this is what we found to be the
best way
to do it because it takes care of all
the problems from the previous three
methods i discussed like it doesn't
discard parts of the image it doesn't
under sample
and it doesn't well the grid sampling
was something different but it doesn't
it's still stochastic where you still
get the randomness aspect that we want
and uh what an interesting side effect
was from this was like in traditional pd
thresholding
you don't count holes that are on the
edge so like here this would not be
common as a whole
but because like here but when you take
the sample now this piece here it is
counted as a whole
because it's fully enclosed on all sides
so basically to rectify this we
basically when we do the traditional pd
thresholding
we just apply like a one pixel length
border around this whole square
and that's sort of now it does count the
holes that are on the edges at which
core
which corresponds to how the persistent
or periodic boundary can
sampling does it so we overall get a
higher kind of hole but still it's still
as long as we're consistent between
the original method and then our method
it it works out
so now we are uh we're going to going to
talk about the ultimate algorithm and
statistical estimator that we developed
so first the first step is to
pre-process and smooth the image
the second step is to generate a large
number n of sample sub images
and then count the number of holes in
each sample using pd thresholding
so we're still ultimately using the pd
thresholding the persistent homology
algorithms
but since we're doing it on a smaller
sample it's a lot faster than doing it
on the whole thing
because as we said before the the
complexity increases cubically
so doing a smaller sample has a lot of
savings with respect to time
and then we compute the sample mean and
the number of holes observed among the n
samples and then multiply the sample
mean by
a quote-unquote population size scaling
factor to estimate the true number of
holes
so like with traditional statistics um
you just multiply it by like you could
say let's say you get a sample mean from
a group of people
and then you multiply by the size of say
the population of the state of illinois
and that's how you get the estimator for
the state of illinois
and here we're treating population size
to be like the s the whole size in the
image
so our scaling factors calculated as a
ratio of between the size of the
original image
and the size of the sample image so if
the original image with the firm data
they were typically 500 by 500
and our samples were typically 125 by
125
so the scaling factor here would be 16.
so we would after we give the sample
mean we would multiply it by 16 and
that's our
overall estimator for the number of
holes in that image
and here are some test case images that
we use containing 4
5 9 12 and 20 holes the
since these were like these were just
things i made in ms paint and they were
just
they're perfectly binary so it removes
the aspect of the noise just for test
calculations to see if the algorithm to
evaluate the algorithm
so probably encountered with that is
that
the expected value for the number of
holes tend to over count or under count
depending on if a border was applied to
samples so like i said before we had to
because the periodic boundary sampling
uh acts as like a wraparound it counts
the holes on the edge
we had to apply a border to
to accurately count or to make maintain
consistency
between the original and our method so
for instance here are just some samples
from those images from before
so without the border this counts no
holes because they're both on the edge
and then with the border accounts two
holes
where really you have like if you were
to like combine them there's roughly one
hole and here
same thing it's either zero holes or
three holes depending on if a border is
applied or not
and so this was giving us results either
severely under counting or severely over
counting
true month holes so we corrected for
this by giving holes on the edges and
corners a weight of one-half
and one-fourth respectively so each hole
here will be weighted as a half
so a half plus a half is one so this
would estimate one whole
and then here each of these this will be
given a half and each of these will be
given a quarter since they're corners
so that'd be a half plus a quarter plus
a quarter which is
still one so that that kind of works
because if you look at these even though
there's
three they kind of constitute almost one
piece of a hole
and then this is just one and so on
and this weighting um and this weighting
greatly helped us like get accurate
results they're not not too much not too
little
and in terms of implementation what this
involved was
iteratively adding borders to each edge
or pair of edges
so to calculate how many holes were on
this if a hole was
on this edge we just add a border here
and then
calculate the do the pd thresholding
again here to p thresholding and then
and then to get the corner pieces we
applied it to two edges at the time
so this got expensive so i know we were
trying to reduce the complexity but this
did get kind of expensive
because and especially in three
dimensions but in two dimensions it
wasn't that bad so it was expensive but
an accurate approach
so application results on the synthetic
data
so we took 100 sample summary sub images
and calculated the sample mean of the
number of holes
and then we repeated the process a
thousand times basically sort of a
bootstrap approach so each
trial uh it consists of 100 samples and
so this is kind
of trying to bootstrap it to see if in
the end would it converge to the true
mean
and just just again here are the
synthetic data
and in the end we saw that this really
did work pretty well so we did the
bootstrap samples
so you can see that the means this one
was around four around five
nine twelve and twenty so we were really
glad to see that this method did work
with a large enough sample size
and on the synthetic data so it did work
pretty well
that and you can see here that the
sample means like each distribution
looks approximately normal
and the mean of the distribution
converge converge to the true mean which
is the true number of holes
and then now applying this to the real
fern data
with the ice so here are just three
images of fern data so for all these
cases uh we first did it in two
dimensions
and so here are just three examples of
two-dimensional fern data with these
images
and the true betty numbers here are this
one's 2
25. and we're mainly looking at since
we're
trying to count the whole like the
one-dimensional holes or which is the
holes in the ice
we're mainly concerned with the betty
one number here
so this has two just because there's
this extra piece in the upper left
corner here but so 225
117 and 115
and then when we ran the algorithm so
this is the betty one by
persistence diagram thresholding or the
original method
and then this is by our algorithm and
then this is by
my domain expert means um dr keegan the
one who collected this data she looked
at it and she said
this is how many holes there are so
and these images come from three
different depths and you can see that
the algorithm would uh ended up being a
lot closer than
the persis the original persistence
diagram thresholding
so 25 uh this gave 16 to 17 and this
gave 15 and that's
about 15. so as you can see our
algorithm did perform better than the
persistence diagram thresholding
and just to compare the fern layers so
as i said in the beginning
there were 10 layers of fern and so it
was just an interesting to see
how many holes were there in the various
layers of fern so
so there are these the ten stacks of
images
and we computed the the betty one or the
number of one dimensional holes
in each image in the entire stack and
then we plotted each of them as a box
and whiskers plot here
and basically we can see the orange line
represents the median
amount of holes in each stack and we can
see that the the
yeah the shallower depth samples like
the centimeters 17 meters
it had a lot fewer holes typically than
like the deeper ones
like the 78 meters like there's more
holes in the deeper ones which makes
sense because in the shallower ones
it's typically more open to the air
above
and so it's not like there are like
tunnels but they're not closed off
and we're really interested in the
closed off ones so
you can see that as it gets deeper there
are more and more closed off holes
and that was something interesting that
we found which corresponds to like the
real scientific data
so another thing that we that i worked
on
with this project that kind to kind of
speed things up was parallelization
and basically the generation so taking
the samples and calculating the bet e1
of each sample can be paralyzed because
each operation is completely independent
from each other all you have to do is
calculate the holes and then once you
have all the data if you just like
store it somewhere you can take the mean
at the end so that means that
parallelization was a great a very good
way of speeding it up
and so i utilize python's
multi-processing package
and like i said greatly speeds up the
computations and this was done on the
university of north carolina chapel
hills
of their longleaf computing cluster
which consists of many
nodes and each node has so much like 24
cpus
so i was able to run many things in
parallel
and so trials were run for sampling in a
3d case so
i did a good bit of work with the 3d
case but none of it was entirely
conclusive because
it was it took some time or not not not
necessarily time but just time to like
implement because
the the sample or the weighting approach
i described earlier
it was like in the in the 2d case you
could see that it would take a lot
because you have to iter
iteratively add an edge to each side and
recalculate and recalculate
in three dimensions you that takes even
more because instead of just edges and
corners you also have like
the faces of the sample cube because in
this case we're dealing with sample
cubes
but uh i could tell even from just
without
conclusive results the conclusive part
was that it would it was much much
faster so
as you saw before uh when i showed the
plot of the runtime
it took like it got up to taking
i think a few times when i ran the 3d
case on the full
the full power of data both on my own
computer and on the cluster
it took about two or three hours
sometimes four hours for the full 3d
fern sample
but when you paralyze it using the
sampling technique
it only took 10 to 20 minutes so that's
one of the
greater advantages of this sampling
technique is that since it can be
paralyzed you can speed it up rapidly
like the
the direct persistence calculation
cannot be parallel
paralyzed to my knowledge at least
because it involves
remembering things in each part they all
are interconnected whereas opposed to
each sample here is independent from
each other
and then um just future ideas uh
increasing the implementation efficiency
because like i said
in 2d the edges the edge cases were a
lot just to begin with so in 3d
if there's a way to uh do the waiting
without needing to
add it edges iteratively that would be
an idea
and then of course a full implement
implementation of the three-dimensional
image data
um because like i said here the the data
and all my results were basically on the
two-dimensional data
and i did some work with the
three-dimensional data but uh
not like the basically the program ended
before i finished
getting all that done because this was
part of an reu
and then exploring different
pre-processing methods because i
basically only talked about two
different kinds here the svd
and the morphology but there are so many
more like there's like gaussian filters
there's maybe even something to do with
convolutional neural networks or even
exploring how this may connect to like
deep learning in general
like with image recognition and then of
course the end goal is to just have an
algorithm
and put all the 3d fern data all 10 all
10 data sets
into an algorithm and get the number of
holes outputted from each
from each calculation and then if you're
interested
in further reading uh here are just
three papers the first paper here
is talks about like it goes into detail
with the mathematical background of
persistent homology
and like just the the nitty-gritty
mathematics behind
all this and then the second paper here
is my two of my mentors
this is where they describe the
persistence diagram thresholding
and then uh myself and my co-authors we
all
we published a paper describing
everything here in this talk today
so you can look at that as well and
that's all i had thank you for listening
to this presentation
thanks victoria um i would like to kick
it off with the first
question i thought this was really
fascinating um
this one might be a i hope it's not too
much in the weeds um
on slide 23
there's a table that i thought was just
so great
um you know this is really exciting
right like
your album compared to pdt
um so i just wanted to clarify the
algorithm that you have with the sub
sampling
is that something done on top of pdt or
you can do it to the original
unbinarized image
good question so basically so in this
case
pdt refers to performing pdt on just the
entire image
but yes pdt is used in the calculation
of each subsample so
each subsample does use utilize the pdt
so it's within
the ba within like the algorithm
presented here but
since it's on a smaller size it's both
faster and
it's a bit more accurate as well so like
pgt is but whereas here pdt or first or
just on the
on just the original image got it
that makes sense and then this part that
you said
i think you had a slide with the waiting
and saying
you do one half for an edge and a
quarter for
and you said the way to get your code to
do that
is just basically just add edges
around um and it seemed that you were
saying that that was the part that
slowed down your program
and i was wondering why that is couldn't
you just add edges
you don't have to guess you can just add
edges all around all the way around
so if you so the reason it slows down
things is because you have to add edges
one at a time and the reason because if
you add
i did like edges to all four sides at
once you're basically calculating
all the number of holes within this
image including the ones on the edge
so adding an edge to the entire border
this would spit out two
and this would give three one four and
three
whereas we want to calculate because in
order to apply the weight so we need to
count
basically it comes down to counting the
number of holes
that are completely within the image
like this one and then so and then so
there's basically three groups the
number of holes completely within the
image
the number of holes on the edge of the
image so like like
these two and then the number of holes
on the corners and
so i'm sorry yeah so here if we apply
all four
apply an edge to all four edges then
it's basically counting
every single hole whereas here so it
doesn't distinguish between
complete holes edge edge holes and
corner holes and we need that
distinction in order to perform the
weighting
right right so you have to count the
holes and then walk around the edge
to to check which ones were like on the
edge and which one around the corner yes
the last question is um
did you try experimenting with different
sizes of the
subsamples like if these sub samples
you're showing are like 10 by 10 pixels
like
experimenting with like 20 by 20 pixels
or something did that make things run
faster
yes so let me go i'll just go with this
slide so yeah that's another good
question
so basically what we did so each of
these images
is like 500 by 500 and the sample we
typically used 125 by 125
or 150 by 150 because if you which is
basically
um in the grid sampling it's basically
each each one of these rectangular
each one of these gray squares would be
125 by 125.
and the reason for that is that if we
have too
small of an image then it won't it will
never catch in a whole hole like if it's
only like if it's super tiny like it
will never every hole that appears will
just be like
a side of a hole it will never catch an
entire hole
but on the other side on the other end
if it's too big
then you run into the same problem that
we're trying to solve anyway that it's
too
computationally expensive so yes um
smaller samples do
run faster so we wanted a balance
between
small enough that it's it saves time but
also
large enough that actually captures
holes and so 125 or 150 was typically
the uh the best range we found and that
was just by manual like experience
gain with these images yeah looking at
lots of these pictures
um yeah that's great thanks
um does anyone else have any other
questions i think
anyone can just unmute themselves
or feel free to put in the chat if
that's more accessible to you
uh yeah i had a couple of questions so
i guess i could start with on on this
slide here um
when you're picking a random pixel and
you're using that sort of
uh lower right hand corner to build the
box
did you experiment with well what if
instead of
you know having to do this iterative
about you know placing the borders
uh or padding the border um what if you
just know that if you pick a random
pixel
then what if you change your you know
where you're
drawing that square so if say the random
pixel is
towards the lower left corner then you
build the
um the box to the you know the upper
left
part of that random pixel so you're not
doing that sort of overlapping
um was that something that was done in
this
in this project it's to see if there's
any sort of
um you know accuracy gains by doing it
that way
or so we know we didn't try that but
so just thinking about it i think it
would cause this
a similar undersampling problem as just
the like the one
going back here just the restricted
domain because you're still basically
you're picking something and then you're
extending it such that
it just we don't want it to go past the
border and so these the parts on the
edge still
um actually because i guess you're
saying so you're saying if you pick a
pixel here instead of going out and to
the right you go like
up and to the right right
well yeah that's that's an interesting
actually now i think about that
that might be feasible i'm not i mean
yeah we never thought about that during
this project but yeah that might be
something to think about like put under
the future work section
all right yeah cool and then um i had
another question um
it wasn't clear so the the pdt is that a
um a filtration that you apply to the
image and then you compute like the
simplicial complex
for um doing the betty number so let me
go back to that so
um i think i'm missing apart from my
site
because normally there's this when you
do the the pdt
there are these like these side things
each represent like they're
it's like births minus deaths over
over something else over i'm not sure if
it's lifespan or something else
but basically these all have like an
algebraic representation and basically
you're trying to maximize basically this
r you take the arg max of the product of
these three things
and then you and then that's what this
is weighted towards like
like the numerator represents like the
long lifespan features and then the
denominator or the part
because you want you want more of these
and less of
these so to speak and i'm not quite sure
about like
the complex aspect because like i'm not
i don't do much work or any work with
topology so i'm not entirely sure about
that aspect of it but i just know it's
something that's utilized in this
process
okay because that that was that would
have been a follow-up question would be
because i know there there's the
virtorus rips uh
complex which is fairly common i was
wondering if maybe
computing a different kind of uh
simplicial complex
has um uh faster run times versus
the the rips but yeah that would be if
you if you look at the paper that would
be something to ask
um dr if you're really interested you
definitely please email one of the
co-authors because i know
i know not much about that aspect of
this all right
it's fire
all right i think that's all my
questions so thank you
no problem
well anyone else anyone on mute or off
camera wanna
chime in
okay well in that case it's been very
lovely to have you victoria
thank you so much for speaking at our
meetup
thank you yeah this recording will be
posted in a week or so to our youtube
channel and everyone will get an
announcement about it on the meetup page
and stay tuned for our next meetup we're
roughly
last thursdays of the month
okay okay have a good night everybody
bye thank you